that Fascination is sort of what drives
me to um you know work with them and and
I still find them fascinating but part
of it is like how how do they do that
how do they have that know where is that
knowledge stored like I understand
software if I tell eeko was written was
you know I wrote that because I was like
okay if I have gpt2 and I ask it to
complete this sentence heo airport is
located in the city of and I have it
generate the next token yeah it says
London yeah where is yes I downloaded
this software onto my laptop I need to
know where is this information stored
how is it able to do that so just the
mechanics of it but also um you know
where the information was stored so that
was a little bit of my my my focus on uh
developing these tools and recently some
of my there's a lot of yeah mechanistic
sort of interpretation um focus on it
but one of my favorites uh is the work
by David ba on Rome where they get to
edit the information